para a sua sua falta
também vindo com as operações on não dá
pra enxergar muito bem vocês aí não é
pessoal boa tarde é uma felicidade muito
grande estar aqui com vocês hoje
na edição passada eu estava na platéia
hoje tenham essa felicidade imensa de
poder estar aqui trocando um pouco de
idéias com vocês
a nossa conversa hoje aqui pessoal vai
passar por um exercício de imaginação
não vamos no primeiro momento imaginar
que eu viesse hoje apresentar para vocês
uma proposta de nós criarmos aqui com
essa galera descolada que nós temos aqui
uma grande empresa um case de
empreendedorismo social vamos criar hoje
uma empresa que presta serviços
gratuitos na área de saúde educação
segurança quando apresentar essa ideia
pra vocês certamente a imensa maioria de
vocês vão dizer por fabiano legal essa
ideia é muito importante nós precisamos
de empreendedores sociais nessa área
precisamos de cidadãos que cumpram essa
necessidade que o nosso país hoje tem
tão grande
aí eu ia continuar com esse exercício de
imaginação ea contar pra vocês outras
condições para criar essa empresa é como
os serviços são gratuitos nós vamos
precisar girar essa empresa vão precisar
de pessoas que mantenham ela não é
financeiramente e essa é a função de
vocês a minha proposta é que cada um de
vocês ajude a manter essa nossa empresa
para você começar a pensar se isso é
viável não pensa em um valor
imaginem que a gente queria colocar
nossa empresa cerca de 40 50% do que
vocês ganham a minha proposta primeira é
essa
todo mês eu todo dia vocês pegam metade
de tudo o que vocês ganham repassam para
essa nossa empresa pra gente poder tocar
ela
a outra proposta seria que a gente
conseguisse achar o maior número de
pessoas que também topasse fazer isso em
uma terceira condição que eu ia colocar
idéias é uma pessoal
contribuem me deram carta branca para
administrar
eu escolho quem é o contrato eu defino
qual é o salário que eu vou receber o
definir quais são os serviços que nós
vamos fazer
e vocês não me pedem muita satisfação a
respeito disso afinal a gente vai ter aí
uma boa bom montante de dinheiro né tem
gente que ganha bem é que eu estou vendo
por aí
henry vai dar um montante bom dinheiro
se não me peçam satisfação porque vou
estar muito ocupado para gerenciar tudo
isso e aí acabou a nossa empresa mas vão
dizer por fabiana ninguém é louco
ninguém vai topar a entrar numa dessas
aí né
não tem não tem condições e aí é que
começa a nossa reflexão de hoje seja
pararam pra pensar que a gente faz isso
todo dia
através dos impostos que estão embutidos
em todos os produtos e serviços que a
gente consome a gente repassa para o
estado cerca de metade do que a gente
ganha pra que ele ofereça esses serviços
gratuitos e com qualidade na segurança
na saúde na educação
essa é a primeira constatação de hoje lá
em 1983 margaret thatcher já dizia é não
existe dinheiro público nem eu a chamava
isso de verdade fundamental
não existe dinheiro público que existe é
o dinheiro dos pagadores de impostos
muita gente não percebe isso é porque a
gente não vai lá todo dia no fim do mês
com um boleto no banco escrito imposto e
o valor lá 200 reais 400 reais 602 mil
enfim mas começa a praticar isso vai no
supermercado pega o cupom fiscal e olha
quanto de imposto tem lá quando você
paga a conta do supermercado a conta do
posto de gasolina conta da farmácia e no
brasil essa realidade é mais cruel ainda
porque os nossos impostos incidem
eminentemente sobre o consumo
então aquele cara que gasta tudo o que
ganha é o que proporcionalmente mais
paga imposto
o cara salarial do que recebe salário
dele no quinto dia útil mil reais por
mês até o dia 10 ele vai gastar tudo
aquilo ali na padaria na farmácia ou
supermercado posto de combustível conta
de água conta de luz
gastou tudo e tem muito pouco de retorno
nisso né mais cruel ainda se você
imaginar que ele beba do indigente
a sinaleira pedindo esmola aquele cara
não tem propriedade nenhuma não tem bem
nenhum não tem onde cair morto mas ele
vai pegar aquelas bolinhas vai lá
comprar uma garrafa de cachaça e 70 por
cento daquilo imposto né tá lá o dia
inteiro trabalhando
o governo então pessoal essa é a
realidade nós somos os sócios
majoritários dessa grande empresa que é
o estado e é mais triste notícia que
vocês sabem tão bem quanto eu a nossa
empresa não vai nada bem ou vai
segundo o instituto brasileiro de
planejamento tributário são entre os 30
países com as maiores cargas tributárias
do mundo o brasil é o último colocado
índice de retorno da qualidade de
serviço que ele presta um outro número
que a gente tenha do próprio governo das
próprias instituições de controle
o tribunal de contas da união ea
controladoria geral da união estimam que
25 por cento desses recursos são
escopeta o ralo devido à corrupção e
principalmente também a ineficiência da
nossa máquina pública a ineficiência
nada dos serviços que são prestados da
forma como isso é gerido então e por
outro lado como que nós sócios da
empresa reagimos um instituto de
pesquisas paranaense perguntou pra
população é como você acha que o cidadão
deve participar da vida pública quando a
pergunta genérica 86% disseram não a
coisa tá feia nós temos que monitorar os
políticos temos que monitorar os gastos
públicos
aí a segunda pergunta apontava o dedo e
você que respondeu à pergunta como você
está participando da vida pública
aí 59 por cento do pessoal respondeu não
eu voltei na última eleição e cumpri o
meu dever cívico e eu fiz a minha parte
então esse é o nosso panorama hoje nós
temos uma indignação ou seja 86% acham
que nós devemos controlar
vamos monitorar mas temos ainda muito
pouca atitude ou seja nós estamos aqui
votando esperando que e agora em 2018
vai chegar um grande salvador da pátria
com raios luminosos de prosperidade para
todo lado e em 2019 vamos estar todos
felizes da vida e morando numa suíça e
por aí vai
ea coisa não é isso né pessoal e é por
isso que eu estou aqui hoje eu quero
contar pra vocês uma história de uma
galera da qual eu tenho honra de fazer
parte que resolveu transformar essa
indignação em atitude que são os
observatórios sociais é uma rede que
existe no brasil já está em mais de 120
cidades e eu tenho a honra de presidir
aqui imagens junto com muita gente que
voluntariamente faz parte e o que a
gente faz nesses observatórios a gente
levou à risca aquele ditado que é meio
lageano também né
é o olho do dono que engorda o boi e é
isso que nós fazemos nós temos lá
engenheiros donas de casa é advogados
contabilistas empresários que se reúnem
se reunirão pra colocar o olho sobre as
contas públicas
para acompanhar o que o estado é o que o
governo quer que o nosso prefeito está
fazendo com o nosso dinheirinho dos
impostos que cai todo mês
lá no cofre e aí ali a gente vai às
escolas falar com as com as crianças
falar sobre cidadania sobre educação
fiscal sobre essa valor social do
imposto
a gente vai lá pra dentro da prefeitura
acompanhar o certame da licitação para
que não haja combinações por lá a gente
acompanha os editais de licitação
comparamos preço pra ver se o preço está
sendo pago é compatível com o mercado e
assim vai
nós vamos lá dentro da prefeitura ajudar
a receber os produtos que os
fornecedores estão vendendo vamos
conferir a qualidade à quantidade
infinda que lá tudo certo e quando
encontramos alguma coisa que não está de
acordo usamos o nosso grande é direito
como cidadão que está na constituição
que é de peticionar ao nosso governo
antes pra que ele conserte algo de
errado então vai um ofício senhor
prefeito
nós cidadãos lageanos detectamos que no
momento da entrega do produto aconteceu
isso que no edital tem este problema e
solicitamos um outro direito nosso que é
o direito de informação solicitamos a
seguinte informação qual providência
será tomada a respeito e com isso a
gente consegue é gerar grandes ganhos
para o nosso município
no ano passado a prefeitura estava
fazendo uma licitação de compra de
cadeiras para auditório o preço que
estava lá no na licitação era 800 cerca
de 850 reais
nós fizemos uma pesquisa de mercado e
vimos que aquela cadeira no no comércio
e se comprava por cento e quarenta reais
e informamos isso o prefeito o senhor
prefeito esta cadeira que vocês estão
comprando por cento por 850 reais pode
ser comprada por cento e quarenta e ele
cancelou a compra e nós geramos uma
economia de 90 mil reais para o
município
só com essa atitude em outra ocasião
nosso voluntário estava lá na sala de
licitações
o fornecedor falou para o outro você
jamais vai conseguir entregar esse papel
higiênico e por esse preço que você tá
prometendo não existe milagre esse preço
está menor do que o custo e o nosso
voluntários bom eu sou obrigado a
acompanhar essa entrega para ver se
existe milagre ou não né
e ele estava lá no dia que o caminhão
chegou chegou o caminhão de papel
higiênico 600 fardos de papel higiênico
e tinha os 600 fardos 48 rolos em cada
fardo em 48 rolos em cada fardo mas ele
acompanhou certame ele sabia que não
existe milagre
e aí ele resolveu desenrolar o rolo de
papel higiênico e ele se enrolou e um
rolo que devia ter 30 metros tinha 21 22
23 e em suma o fornecedor estava
entregando 210 quilômetros a menos de
papel higiênico e tudo isso foi
devolvido e nós evitamos que o
fornecedor passasse a perna nem nós
mesmos na nossa empresa
o município é isso que a gente faz lá no
observatório recentemente uma licitação
de água mineral mesma coisa simplesmente
o preço dela 5.000 bombonas de água
o preço era 19 reais e nós perguntamos
nós informamos que o edital não não
deixava claro se o fornecedor teria que
poderia levar embora bombom não é a
questão do comodato
só com essa pergunta o preço diminuiu de
19 para 13 6 reais vezes 5.000 bombonas
30 mil reais de economia que foram
gerados
e esses exemplos vão se repetindo todo
dia ea gente vai começando a ver como é
importante a nossa preocupação a nossa
participação enquanto cidadão quanto é
importante nós sócios da empresa
estarmos como olho lá em cima ea gente
vê que a gente começa a influenciar as
políticas que a gente começa a
influenciar o pensamento do gestor
quando ele vê que o cidadão não tá só
cobrando mas ele está contribuindo ele
está apontando o caminho ele está
ajudando a a cidade andar a gente começa
a entender o significado do verdadeiro
significado da palavra cidadão ou seja
aquele que pertence à cidade
aquele que participa da vida da cidade e
é isso é essa mensagem que nós queremos
deixar para vocês que quanto mais gente
estiver participando de tudo isso quanto
mais a gente vestiu a camisa quanto mais
a gente cobrar mas ao mesmo tempo
participar mas o nosso município nosso
país nossa nosso estado o mundo enfim
vai ser melhor
e essa é a mensagem que eu queria deixar
para vocês hoje muito obrigado
[Aplausos]